et sport toujours du cyclisme sur piste
à présent des championnats régionaux
étaient organisées ce week-end sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
cinquantaine de sportifs venus de toute
l'île de france a participé à
l'événement au programme du scratch de
la vitesse des courses aux points et du
keirin on écoute le conseiller technique
régional d'ile-de-france francisco cause
aux micros des médias limitrophes ya
tous les niveaux il ya des gens qui sont
qui se font plaisir ça va des meilleurs
amateurs élite aux meilleurs juniors
et les meilleurs en fat régionaux et
départementaux tout le monde est
regroupé dans la même épreuve les
championnats régionaux sont quand même
les épreuves qui sont les épreuves de
référence qui nous servent à faire les
sélections pour les championnats de
france notamment les premiers
championnats de france qui auront lieu
en juillet à hyères championnat de
l'avenir
on observe notamment les juniors juniors
cadets juniors